you
my specific job is supervising sound
editor and in some cases Co supervising
sound editor and I'm kind of usually
responsible for all the dialogue editing
all the ADR sort of all the words and
then in this in some cases I work with
Eugene Garrity who's more the sound
designer comes up with sound effects I
think to excel in sound editing mostly
you just have to want to do it and you
really have to be able to collaborate
our job essentially is to try to to get
the director to try to help the director
achieve his or her vision it's mostly
important to realize that most directors
will are thrilled if you come up with
something that they didn't think of or
wouldn't have thought of but primarily
you're there to serve the film and to
help tell the story the best way you can
usually I will get it sent a script
primarily to help do budgeting with the
film because if the film has a budget
which some don't have much of one it's
helpful to see on paper what you might
be faced with maybe get some ideas of
what might need to be recorded how long
it might take to do the job and also
just to get a feel for the film
generally as the film is being shot and
edited will get called upon to simply
furnish sound effects or occasionally if
there's a particularly bad sounding
dialogue scene to do a little bit of
work on it and maybe mix it a little bit
and then give stuff back to the editor
to use in their process for screenings
and then at a certain point when the
film is relatively close to being locked
they'll turn over the film and will
start the process of working on the
dialogue and
the sound effects and all the other
pieces and that's usually a eight to ten
week process then would go into the into
the dubbing stage into the mix for
anywhere from three to eight or ten
weeks again depending on the the size of
the film and then we eventually make a
print master and then do an
international track without the dialogue
and we're sort of the last ones usually
on the process good sound editing to me
depends completely on the type of film
that you're watching and listening to if
it's an action movie then there can be a
temptation to just keep piling on one
sound and after another it eventually
just becomes a cacophony you can't
there's no detail anymore I think an
action film benefits by having very
specific sounds that are good and clear
and do the job and then get out of that
one and move on into the next one if
it's an emotional scene in and suddenly
there's a a jet going by overhead it
might sort of take you out of the out of
the scene so I think on some films less
is more and on a narrative film I think
if you're not aware of the sound at all
and yet you're feeling all the emotion
involved then the sound editor did a
good job film that I that did inspire me
and this was after I had long been a
sound editor was Terminator 2 because
it's the kind of it's an action film it
doesn't become this big wash of sound
and the music complemented the sound
effects and vice versa and that to me
was a very good example of what could
have just been a lot of noise but was
very detailed Scorsese was in LA for
many years and he came back wanted to
come back and work in New York and he
was sort of looking for a new york-based
sound team I worked with a partner named
skip love say for several years and he
did a film called after hours
which was the first film that Marty did
in New York after coming back and I
think he was very pleased with the job
and I was started working with skip a
little bit after that and I guess my
first Scorsese job was Michael Jackson
video bad and that was about 1986 and
since then I've just kind of worked on
on everything and skip moved to Los
Angeles so wasn't really available to
continue so I sort of kept it up and
continued after he left I have a very
good relationship with Marty he we love
to make each other laugh so I'm sort of
the class clown on the mixed stage I
keep him happy he keeps us happy he's a
very charming man very funny
he is very specific about what he wants
it's very there's there's very little
question whether he likes something or
he doesn't he won't stop until it's the
way he wants it to be yet there's a lot
of room even in those places but
certainly throughout the rest of the
film to just experiment and do what you
want and he's always willing to listen
to something one of the greatest
challenges on Hugo in terms of the
dialogue and the production sound was
there's steam everywhere all through the
train station you see steam shooting out
of every vent or coming up through the
floor or down from the ceiling
all of those sequences were were very
noisy with the steam itself and the
machines that made the steam there were
lots of challenges for the production
sound mixer to try to cleanly mic the
actors and and that became my challenge
because Marty Scorsese and Thelma
Schoonmaker the editor get very it's all
about the emotion of the scene
technically they couldn't they do care
but they don't get bogged down in is
this like a perfectly pure take it if
take
is the one that they want it has the
right sound they don't care if a wrench
falls and clangs on the floor it's more
about getting the right emotional
quality from the scene so a lot of time
and effort was put into trying to get
the clean that clean up the production
sound to get rid of the steam as much as
possible
there were several microphones used in
in each scene radio mics and boom mics
and normally I try to use a boom mic
track and then sort of embellish it with
the radio mic only for the voice itself
and then kind of weave in and out of
that but in this case the boom tracks
were so noisy in most cases that we just
had to use a radio mic which means
picking up crackle and move whenever
anybody moves so it was a real challenge
just to try to clean up the tracks and
and get everything heard and get
everything to poke through the
additional sounds that that take place
in scenes where radio mics were used or
things where the dialogue was replaced
everything has to be added in but that's
kind of the case for everything all the
time anyway because eventually you have
to have an international track where the
dialogues the English dialogue is
removed and it's dubbed in one of many
languages so and pretty much everything
you see on the screen you have to have a
sound for eventually whether using the
production dialogue sounds or not my
favorite sequence in Hugo was one that I
did very little work on myself but my
partner Eugene Garrity did a great job
and that's sort of the the dream
sequence with the Train Hugo jumps down
on the track to try to pick up a key and
then the train's coming towards him and
it eventually goes off the track and
goes barreling through the station and
out the window
that's a good example I think of what I
was talking about before which is having
a lot of stuff going on
and hitting kind of one detail at a time
and having it build and build but not
some like a mush of of every sound
you've ever heard coming in at you all
at the same time
I think that's probably my favorite
sequence in that film